hi
everyone welcome to this live session by
simply learn
today's topic is final year project tips
in today's session we'll give you all
the tips that will help you ace your
final year project
but before we begin i'd like to thank
our viewers on youtube and facebook for
actively participating in these sessions
so let's wait for a while for people to
tune in
once again i welcome everyone to this
live session by simply learn
if you have any questions do feel free
to leave them in the chat section and we
will be happy to answer them
also make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
now let's get started we have 7 vital
tips that will help you complete your
final year project successfully
we will look into each one of these tips
individually so without further ado
let's start with our first tip
first and foremost choosing the right
topic holds paramount importance
with the number of options available
today this decision can be overwhelming
you must ensure that the topics you
choose are related to your field of
study and that is of interest to you
you will be required to deep dive into
your topic hence you must choose a topic
that interests you
it is recommended that you have a topic
that has a strong motive
in many cases projects that help mankind
is highly recommended
in addition to that research and choose
topics that aren't common and
traditional
this will help you stand out from the
others
now let's look at a few examples of
projects related to the different
branches of engineering
on your screens you can see the popular
trending projects for computer science
and it
we have chat bots chatbots are getting
widely popular these days and are being
extensively used to solve customer
problems
we have face detection that is used in
companies such as facebook google
and ibm you can also focus on creating
projects related to some current events
such as predicting coronavirus cases
or predicting the upcoming u.s elections
you can create a search engine that
would return relevant links based on
your search term
another interesting project you can do
is to perform sentiment analysis using
python or
r now let's see a few electrical and
electronics projects that might interest
ec
or tripoli students you can create a
simple bluetooth controlled electronic
home appliances project
where you can control different
electrical appliances and electronic
devices using an android device with the
help of bluetooth
technology you can use radio frequency
technology and build a metal detector
robotic system that can help
identify metals in the ground inside a
bag etc
you can build a 5 volt regulated dc
supply from 220 ac to charge
mobiles as well as the power sources for
digital circuits
breadboard circuits ics microcontrollers
etc
electricity is one of the most important
resources and it must be utilized
carefully
you can create a microcontroller based
project that automatically turns on or
off the lights in a room a project on
micro inverters can be used to power
light loads such as night lamps and
cordless telephones
you can modify it into a powerful
inverter by adding more mosfets
now let's discuss a few of the popular
mechanical projects
we would like to remind you that these
projects are not the only ones that you
need to choose
there are a lot of other interesting
projects that you can opt for
in your final year here first we have a
3d printer
you can build a 3d printer machine that
has additive manufacturing techniques in
which 3d objects can be printed with the
help of computer aided design software
you can create a compressed air engine
that does mechanical work by expanding
compressed air
reducing the cost of vehicle production
and consumption of fossil fuels
using modern tools and software such as
autodesk showcase
lightwave 3d alias autodesk and bread
you can create 3d visualizations and
design vehicles
finally we have a conveyor system
project that supports mechanical
handling equipment to move
objects from one location to another
let's now move on to the next step we
have
and that is to choose the right guide
a project guide plays a major role in
defining the success of the project
he or she should be a good mentor who
goes the extra mile for helping you with
your project
the guide you choose should be a
knowledgeable subject matter expert in
the same field as your project
this way even if you get stuck or run
out of ideas your project guide will be
able to help you with it smoothly
it will be an added advantage if your
guide is carrying out research in the
same domain or if he or she has
published research papers in the past
you must be able to add extra weightage
to your project by utilizing your guides
experience and knowledge
in addition to choosing the right guide
also make sure that if it is a group
project
choose the right set of team members to
work with choosing the right members who
are cooperative and equally hard working
is very crucial
so the next step that you need to take
care of seriously is planning your
project
well this might sound very generic but
it is crucial throughout the
process once you have finalized your
project topic
and the guide you have to make extensive
plans as to how to go about the entire
process
you must have a project plan which
covers the goal research
requirements cost estimations
implementation and presentation
planning the project beforehand will
help you streamline your process
and in turn save you from last minute
confusions
make sure to create a plan keeping in
mind the deadlines
it is advised that you break down your
project into faces and then execute them
step by step
a strong project plan can yield better
results than you can imagine
the next step we have for you is to read
all the existing research papers
in the same field as your project you
might wonder how this will help you
well there are several advantages to
this by reading the existing research
papers that are closely related to your
project you will get an idea as to what
content is already there
and what is lacking you need to make
sure that your project has additional
and new information
from the already existing ones for this
purpose you need to be aware of all the
research done previously
reading research papers will also give
you an outline as to how you should
proceed with your work
and what are the kinds of content that
have to be highlighted
moving on to our fifth tip that is to
publish a research paper
publishing a research paper is one of
the ways you can add credibility to your
project
it also gives you more confidence while
presenting your project
in a lot of cases research papers can
also open doors to new opportunities
once you are done writing your research
paper make sure to reference it properly
proofread and
edit check your research paper for
repetitions grammatical errors quotation
rules obeyed and so on
not to forget that research papers add a
great amount of weightage to your resume
the cutouts that you see here are a few
examples of research papers published in
leading journals and professional
associations
related to multiple technologies and
research domains
such as quantum computing augmented
reality
wireless sensor networks axial turbines
and others
it is highly recommended to publish a
paper in peer-reviewed journals that
gives international recognition
for an individual department university
and institutions
it helps in enrolling for higher
education at reputed institutes
you can apply for a career in research
and teaching positions as well
moving on to our next step the next step
you have to keep in mind is to implement
and test your project
well before presenting your project make
sure to implement it and then test it
well
by doing this even if there are any
errors you can fix them
there may be some trials and errors at
first but you would need to keep going
after your project is built it is time
to test it
you can do this with some test cases in
order to check if your project is
yielding the expected results or not
you must ensure that it is aligned with
your project goal and there shouldn't be
any deviations
and a final project tip to you is a
strong presentation
and visualization of your project
there is no point in having worked so
much if you are unable to deliver your
project well on the final day
hence it is of utmost importance that
you're well versed with your project and
make a good presentation on it
while making your presentation keep in
mind that it has to be interesting with
all the required information
making use of data visualization in your
presentation will be an
added advantage and the project results
will be delivered in a crystal clear
manner
during a project presentation there will
be a number of questions from the panel
you should calmly and carefully answer
the questions asked
you can master the art of presentation
with good practice
there you go those were important tips
in order to successfully complete your
final year project
with that we have come to the end of
this live session by simply learn
i hope it was informative and useful if
you think we missed out on any important
tips then please feel free to put it in
the comments section of the video
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel thank you for watching and keep
learning
you